[музика]
[оплески]
так шановні ми починаємо трансляцію Всіх
вітаю якщо буде якісь проблеми зі
звуком вітаємо всіх це буде марш по
Києву Петро Порошенко вийшов щойно з
будівлі державного бюро
розслідувань і ми будемо направлятися
вирушаємо зараз до будівлі суду адмініст
Печерського суду на вулиці
Володимирська всередині в
[музика]
машині
давай так Зараз ми знаходимось тут прямо
в будівлі
тут біля будівлі дбр тут Олександр
погрібиський Андрій Луганський Я за
камерою будемо з вами спостерігати прямо
з
броньовичка
[музика]
бачите там формується
колона і зараз ми пройдемо по Києву чи є
картинка чи є звук ніхто взагалі нічого
не
написав люди Напишіть будь ласка в
чатику чи є звук чи є
картинка второй
второй когда первый станет в голову
когда первый станет в голо
о мікрофончик є все все гаразд все
працює
1010 друзі проходимо за перехрестя
проходимо за перехрестя підтягуємо
колону за Петром олексійовичем Порошенко
рухаємось
прямостали
си
[музика]
друзі протягуємось вперед
підходимо підтягуємось вперед за
перехрестя
це колона зараз вирушає до суду до
Печерського чи печерного суду колона
колона вирушає до Печерського
суду
українціція Я вас прошу
організовано не
виходячи
за смугу руху організовано рухаємось
колоною прямо до Печерського
[музика]
суду
передаємо вітання якщо нас там бачать
люди біля суду бачите скільки
[музика]
людей
Слава Україні Героям слава Слава Україні
Героям слава Слава Україні Героям слава
Слава
нації Слава нації
зровились ми великої години зпожерж
війни і полувя вогнів лекав нас біль за
лю України спростив нас Гнів і людь на
во
ливав нас бі за долю України зростив на
згнів і людь на вороні
[музика]
мийдемоки переможним холодом тверді від
сні не зламні укранін бо плач не дав
нікому ще Свободи
хтоворець той збває свій болаж неба
нікому ще свободи
боретьві свуха і сві Україно Україно
свята Поти герой свята Поти геройди на
серце мого зійди на серце мого за во за
твою слово за й сятійде за твої
дітей тоі
ввою я тобі відро Славою твоєкраниться
славо моєлися страу нехай не зна страу
нехай не знає
я не знаю що
таке
[музика]
щолощо
под усе понад
[музика]
ус велику суть для усіх єдину наш гордий
Клич народові несе
вітчизнігуть тиірний бе зупину нам
Україна вище по все
чисьні вірний без у приду на Україна
Ще Поло
[музика]
все друзі Слава Україні Слава
нагадую колону очолює п'ятий та сьомий
президент України Петро Олексійович
Порошенко разом
з нашим улюбленим пастором Олександром
валентиновичем
турчиновим друзі рухаємось організовано
не виходимо за смугу
рухумуку зараз колона повертає праворуч
колона повертає
[музика]
праворуч
мені казали Привет мені казали здраствуй
Давай до свідания казали мені і все це
було нормально все було Не страшно Якби
було в Пітері або в Москві але такими
словами мене встрічає столиц
жовтоблакитної країни що чекає на транш
вона Чомусь не розуміє моєї мови коли я
кажу привіт мене питають ти
Львова Ні я з України це навпроти Європи
це там Тик це там де Дніпро Ні я з
України проти вас і але мені треба знати
Хто тут Хто так я з
України Так я з
[музика]
України і на стіні когос не каже все
чком і кожен день розпочинається гімном
і торочина біла і мова солов'їна на усіх
каналах Добрий вечір Україна як тут бути
нащойце Кати одна земля і Донбас і
Карпати але не чуєть мене країна моя
мова просто класна а не соло
Так я з України це на проти ро це це
даро так я з України проти вас не але
мені треба знати Хто тут Хто я з
[музика]
України
друзі Я трошки відстав від головної
машини щоб просто показати вам всю
колону просто от зараз ви дивитесь
колону вітаю вітаю друже вітаю
вітаю Слава Україні Героям
слава Вінниця Вінниця Вітаю Вінниця
вітаємо самий класний плакат молодпо
все клас це
суперово порох є дамо
[музика]
вогню порох сила порох
сила свободна Укра бачи скільки людей
свободна
Україна Вітаю
дівчата
українаку
Дякую А зараз буде маленька така
пробіжечка я просто пробегу до початку
колони бо треба їхати разом з усіма я не
можу вам показати всю колону бо там ще
дуже багато бачите дуже багато людей а я
зараз так от зроблю раз і трошечки
побіг так буде щчас не дуже зручно бо я
отак
Отак буде трошки зручніше і я побіг
[музика]
чатик чатик якщо є запитання
пишіть боки тут
я
30тиградусного жару побігаю може там
захейкаюсь вам щось розкажу
це ми зараз біля метро
Університет чую Сашко погребиський там
десь
[музика]
попереду зараз прямо в
колоні так буде
швидше
Порошенко
[музика]
тягуємо
всекту тобі
дої перед вашими очима щоб ви розпитали
муженикі кого коли за що розпинали
обніміте ж брати мої найменшого брата
Нехай Мати усміхнеться за плакана мати
благословить дітей своїх твердими руками
і діточок поцілує вольними устами і
забудеце срамотня давня Ягодина і уживе
добра слава слава
України
Україно
Україно Після
далечні
дорі Вірне
серце твого сина
я кладу тобі
дові
Україно
Україно сирне серце
го синаякладу
[музика]
і
волі
[музика]
Зараз ми проїжджаємо червоний корпус
недалеко увага птя колона підтягується і
голова колони повертає ліворуч зараз
колона буде повертати ліворуч нагадаю
колону очолює Петро Олексійович
Порошенко Олександр Валентинович
турчив а вя фракція пейкої
[музика]
солідарності Слава Україні буде видно що
колонії нема кінця ба Слава
нації Слава
нації
Порошенко
пошенко
[музика]
сучасний музичний формат розрахований на
людей без легені серця головним
конфліктом в більшості композицій є
відсутність конфлікту Найбільш важливою
темою є секс причому
бажано
друзі нагадаю сьогодні
ми разом з вами
зібрались разом з найпотужнішою
опозиційною політичною партією
європейська Солідарність на чолі з
Петром Порошенком сказати своє ні
політичним репресіям
ні політичним
репресіям ні політичним
репресіям політичним репресіям
ні політичним
репресіям Я хочу нагадати владі що ми не
втомимось виходити раз за разом для того
щоб за нагадати владі що ми живемо у
вільній незалежній Україні в якій ніколи
не буде політичних репресій Слава
Україні
ворець той здобуває свій бо влач не дав
нікому ще Свободи
боборець той зногу має світ Україна
Україна ста герой сятавати герой зійди
до серця мого зійди до серцея
мого за твою славу за твої святі ідей за
твої святі ідей не душами я тобі в не
душава я тобі в словою твоєкраміниться
славию моєю ороміниться ску нехай не
знаю я ску нехай не знаю
Я не знаю що таке гойду скри Мій дух Зай
гой що с щоб сміло йшо яі
щоб ві моя
булані що зата
Слава понад усе понад
усе велику суть для усіх єдину наш
гордий Клич народові несе вітчизні густь
ірний бе зупину нам украї Іна вище Пола
Все вічизній
с і вірний безупину на Україна
Ще Пола
все наі героїв наших славах для нас
закон найвищи понака
Соборна
українська є держава
да на біх вяну пора
Соборна
українська є держава
онагі і зану
покас
[музика]
одна одна єдина Соборна Україна одна
єдина Соборна
Україна єдина собор
кра
одна Слава
Україні сла Слава
нації
Україна друзі я нагадаю що ми сьогодні
вийшли цією колоною від дбр до
Печерського суду для того щоб показати
всій Україні всьому світу на чолі з
сомим президентом України Петром
оледійовичем
Порошенко Олександром валентиновичем
турчиновим та всією фракцією
європейської солідарності
що Україна проти політичних репресій
ні політичним
репресіям ні політичним
репресіям
штурм Вери відкривай поро двері ми
прийшли
вжегея
Я кров
солонеболянись хтось завишене
наілясі ми прийшли вже я
[музика]
Я за боївку наварено змелено
алестрадник
мовчав за вікном на горисі
зеленому вітер ноги
гойдав машин бери шторм
говери відкриває А може поруч з судом
вже зараз колона
поверне і ми вже майже
тут Солоне
податись хтось зависне на
діляці ми прийшли вже я
я Маши Вери шторм Вери відкриває бесо за
двері ми прийшлице я
хтось зависне
на ми прийшли вже я
го друзі Ми вже підходимо до будівлі
Печерського
суду
ми не підходимо і зупиняємось ми
проходимо вперед для того щоб зручно
змогли розміститись всі люди які йдуть в
колоні голова колони протягується вперед
всі протягуються за солідарною молоддю
яка йде в голові колони з
банерами протягуємось трохи вперед не
зупиняємось під печерським протягуємось
трохи вперед
щоб за собою закрити всю площу щоб всі
люди змогли зайти на площу Перед
печерським
судом Слава
Україні Слава
нації Слава
нації українці нагадаю колону очолює
смий президент України Петро Олексійович
Порошенко Олександр
Валентинович фракція найпотужнішої
опозиційної політичної сили європейська
Солідарність
[музика]
Порошенко
несправедли вже започаткував таку нову
традицію збирати нас нації Лище і це вже
стало добре диція що вони тут збиралися
і
захищали
пра
і
ці медолугі
ії які робить Влада
вони показують
що вони показують те що ми маємо
об'єднатися
що саме
наш настрій
на
[музика]
шенко Отож друзі ми прийшли приїхали до
суду Хто прийшов Хто прибіг хто приїхав
Ми вже біля будівлі суду оце Печерський
чи Пещерний суд і
зараз ми вже тут майже на місці
[музика]
тримаємось Олександр прямий ефір
завершуй
че чесне і чисте ім'я ми будемо разом
боротися за Україну Слава
[музика]
Україні коли такий величезний натовп іде
по Києву і показує всім Хто тут головний
якщо можна так сказати дуже
реально якась така енергетика вулиці
егтика того що народ об'єднаний однією
ідеєю енергетика того
що ми всі разом і ми всі сила тому я
дякую кожному хто сьогодні прийшов Хто
долучився до цієї ходи і зараз Порошенко
говорить давайте слухати його ми всі
українці незалежно від того якої
національності по наше серце молить За
подальшу долю України Ви
найкращі
що в нас опустяться
руки що ми
втобимося що ми вже ніколи не виколи
людей але ми їм точно не здамо
Україну їх План був
віддати п'ятій колоні Кремля в
оренду правоохоронні органи прокуратуру
силовиків і в та б знищити Україну
поставити її на коліна
їх план пов'язати волонтерів
добровольців почали Софії федини почали
з марус
звіробій почали з наших хлопців і дівчат
звинувативши їх вськи Шеремета почали
зстаді
Черновол Україну ці років бо вони а не
Путін для них найбільша небезпека
ми грудні місяці перший раз вийшли на
акції протесту ми заявили що ми не дамо
перетнути червоні лінії і здати
українську землю тоді вони злякались
тоді вони повернулися з Парижу не
підписавши відведення наш військ зараз
намагалися піти іншим
шляхом скорочення
армії Уявіть собі вони скорочують
найбільш бойові
підрозділи скорочують десантно-штурмові
війська скорочують
морпехів скорочують винищування
ескадрільї повітряних
сил скорочують
[музика]
спецпризначенців ми їх зупинимо
Бо нам з вами боронити українську
землю друга
позиція за їх часів за часів безглуздих
некомпетентних
кварталівців вони повернулись за
кордону всю п'яту
колодку всіх присішників Януковича і
здали їм оренду державне бюро
розслідувань Уявіть собі ще рік тому чи
могли уявити
що спілків адвокатів Януковича очолить
державне бюро розслідувань і будуть
зараз пред'являти підозри і звинувачення
в тому що ми з вами боронимо державу
ми Я Хочу наголосити розслідування
проводиться для того щоби встановити
проправину я
наголошую я сам
визнаю що це я віддав наказ як верховний
головнокомандувач і як п'ятий президент
України Про Контрнаступ в червні 14го
року коли наші збройні сили звільнили
дві третини окупованого
Донбасу звинувачувайте мене в цьому що
це саме я
схвалюю що українські військові кораблі
пішли українською
прою в українське Азовське море щоби
боронити українське узбережжя
українських міст Бердянськ і Маріуполь
звинувачувайте
[оплески]
мене щоце ми з вами доброгі друзі
створили українську армію яка зупинила
російського агресора Я готовий за Це
нести відповідальність і врешті-решт
вони з'їхали з глузду і звинуватили мене
в розпалюванні міжрелігійної ворожнечі
шляхом отримання томосу про автокефалію
і створення православної церкви України
нашої церкви які немає впливу Москви
звинувачувайте в
цьому
дяку Скажіть будь ласка українці можуть
в цьому звинувачувати
ці сценарії виписані точно в
Кремлі точно реалізують кремльвський
сценарій і тому ми сьогодні тут під
судом для того щоби цей сценарій
зупинити сьогодні
вони
Дякую Верховного головнокоманду
президента
України те що на реалізацію своїх
конційних
повноважень я
призначив
керівництво розвідки України для
забезпечення розвідувальної
інформацію збройні сили вони
написали що ми або я
схиляв керівника розвит я як можу
сказати
схиляють дякую корабельну
сосну Я чекаю поки
Зеленський не вибачиться за приниження
його народними депутатами за яких він
особисто за кожного ніс відповідальність
вивачитись перед українськими жінками ми
точно не будемо з ім миритися і терпіти
це
а в судді в суді Ми також будемо
боронити державу в
суді ми будемо притягувати до
відповідальності
безглуздих прокурорів які не знають що
таке конституційна конституційний
принцип принцип презумпції
конституційності
І що в демократичній державі український
громадянин не має доводити свою
невинуватість Ми не в 37му році а вони
не мишинські хоча діють за його лікалами
і за його сценарієм Ми зупинимо їх і
зараз о 2 годині починається засідання
вони дуже розраховували що ми злякаємося
і не
прийдемо ми їх не боїмося навпаки вони
бояться нас з вами вони налякані вони
піджали хвоста і ми переможемо знаєте
чому Бо Україна з нами Бог з нами правда
з нами і перемога буде з нами Слава
Україні
ро слава Слава нації Смерть порога
Україна понад усе дякую кожному з вас що
ми разом Разом до
[оплески]
перемоги А ще я хочу подякувати я хочу
подякувати кожного хто висловив мені
слова
співчуття в цю важку для нашої родини
годину подякувати дружину яка попладуйте
Марині
[оплески]
прошу перша леді завжди поруч і дуже
любить Україну хочу подякувати нашій
фантастичній фракції в Верховній Раді
Олегу синютку Андрію парубію Іванки
клімпуш Ірі Фріз колі княжицькому
Степану кубіву Олексію Гончаренко
ваші
оплескиу
павн
іххто з
нами хочу
подякувати Саша мої діти тут щоб Не
дякували Саша ти молодець Олексій
молодці Олексій ми разом а ще я хочу
подякувати величезній події яка
відбулася вчора ім'я цієї події Кровавий
пастир Олександр
[оплески]
товцінов
for